- Ils tentaient de fuir l'estkrr
de la guerre les a rattrapés.
En pleine gare de Kramatorsk,
où ont circulé des millierss, c,
une effroyable attaque.
des cigarettes là-bas,
et la bombe est tombée,
raconte cet homme, et j'ai vu
que ma grand-mère était morJ'air
des gens plus loin."
L'attaque a:
z..=/♪
a fait des dizaines de morts
L'attaque au missile
a fait des dizaines de morts et
de blessés; parmi les victimes,
Sur le quai de la gare,
des corps gisaient près
des peluches et des valises.
d'un missile où il était écrit
en russe : "Pour nos enfants."
"Il n'y avait pas de personnel
dit le président ukrainien,
seulement des genss
qui tentaient de prendre
le train pour se r
en lieu sûr."
Pendant que la Russie nie t
responsabilité, les Occidentaux
ont condamné l'attaque en bloc..
... qui ne restera pas impuni.
horrible, un cauchemar", dit
la présidente de la Commissionon
européenne, arrivée en Ukraine.
Ursula von der leyen a visité
celui de Boutcha. Le choc...
pouvait se lire suge,
devant une fosse commune.
- Thank you...
- Une démonstration de
solidarité de la dirigeante
européenne, venue discuterd'arms
à l'Ukraine.
(en anglais)
"L'Ukraine marche
vers un avenir européen",
Mais au-delà des mains tendues,
Kiev attend des actions
concrètes, comme un embargo
(en ukrainien)
"Les sanctions doivent
le président ukrainien,
parce que la Russie n'écoute
ni rien, ni personne."taquetaque
contre des civils donne
un triste aperçu des horreurs
qui pourraient attendre l'est
y resserre son étau. Elle met
aussi en évidence les limites
de l'indignation exprimée
et ajoute de la pressionpour dee
plus musclées cont